Disney's d23 event happened in
California over the weekend and we got a
bunch of gaming news out of it here's
the stuff that's happening Square Enix
have announced to the kingdom hearts 3
will include a world based on recent
disney hit big hero 6 the game is also
set to include an antagonist who uses
the powers of darkness to manipulate the
body of baymax for the uninitiated
that's the big white puppy dude you've
probably seen in big hero 6 posters on
top of that it was confirmed that the
events of Kingdom Hearts 3 will take
place after those of the big hero 6
movie we also found out the Disney
infinity is getting Star Wars Episode 7
protagonists spin and Ray both of whom
were featured in the new Star Wars
Episode 7 poster they also revealed at
the same event if straight-up Star Wars
games are more your gem they also
unveiled a Darth Vader themed ps4 for
ps4 is part of a star wars battlefront
special edition bundle which will launch
on November 17 alongside the game it'll
also include the star wars battlefront
deluxe edition a custom dual shock 4
controller inspired by Vader's chest
panel as well as for free digital games
super star wars star wars racer revenge
car wars jedi starfighter and Star Wars
bounty hunter all of these will be
available on TS war for the first time
and supposedly feature enhanced graphics
and trophy support a standard
battlefront bundles was also announced
which includes battlefront the four
digital game and a regular black ps4 and
controller let me know down in the
comments if you like the look of the new
Darth Vader themed console for old Star
Wars and gaming news be sure to stay
tuned the games but
you